oh my goodness
what a handsome bunch here hello welcome
to the VMAs how's it feeling so far um
thank you for inviting us we feel very
very good
um we can't wait to show you guys our
performance
and this performance really uh brings
out a lot of stray kids colors so
definitely there's going to be a lot of
lighting effects there's going to be a
lot of dances so yeah we can't wait to
show our fans
what's a good dance move oh
it's like teach me a move straight kids
yeah we have this we
just oh wait are you saying that I look
like I can't stand no no no that's what
I'm saying I'm just saying you know one
of the simple ones one of the simple
ones I
oh my goodness okay who this is y'all's
first VMAs so who are you looking
forward to seeing meeting interacting
with tonight
[Music]
Olivia Rodrigo
um and and many more you know there's
because you know we've looked forward to
these people while we're growing up so
to meet them here it's it's a big honor
big honor incredible you just
collaborated for a remix of the song
Rush what was the process like of
collaborating on that song
um
it was really really good
um you know because
for him growing up he used to listen to
Troye Sivan as well but like to actually
collaborate with him it's a really big
honor and he's really you know learn a
lot from it and you were up for your
first VMA award tonight
hopefully it happens but then you know
don't want to get our hopes too much
high but hopefully something happens
okay sir one two three four five six
seven eight of you
[Music]
how are you going to do the rotation if
you get the award who's taking the award
home first oh well I mean for us it's
always youngest the youngest is most
powerful so he's gonna take it home okay